let's consider the universal
gravitational law is a little bit more
let's consider two objects in space
let's say this is the Sun and we have
the earth here or the earth and the moon
and of course they're orbiting each
other so we can pick a coordinate system
that goes radially and so we're going to
have an R hat direction here I'm going
to call this the R hat direction between
objects one and two what forces are
acting on this little moon here well
it's the gravitational force going
inward it's the force a 1/2 F 1/2 on
object who due to their interaction
between bodies 1 & 2 for that we can
write down the universal gravitational
law F 1/2 equals minus G the
gravitational constant M 1 M 2 over R 1
2 squared that one is the distance
between the two objects times R 1 2 hat
and the minus goes actually with the
unit vector here because the force goes
in the opposite direction from our R hat
let's now consider here is the earth
again and we're going to move the moon
or a little moon rock right to the
surface of the earth and we want to now
calculate and consider what kind of
forces act on this moon rock and what is
the gravitational acceleration that this
moon rock on the surface of the earth is
experiencing so here we have the earth
earth has one earth radius and it has an
earth mass and our moon rock has the the
mass M and we know from this exercise
here already that of course this
gravitational force is acting on a moon
rock as well that hasn't changed what we
are now considering in addition is that
this moon rock is also experiencing a
gravitational acceleration due to this
force and that goes inward as well so it
is experiencing an M
gee and we know that that is the same as
the magnitude of this force here so we
can equate that with G and then we have
the earth mass and the mass of the moon
rock times the distance squared so
arrayed and earth radius squared and
from that we already see that a we can
cancel out the small M s of the moon
rock and we'll get two G here so we can
calculate the gravitational acceleration
which is capital G earth mass / earth
radius squared so if we have this kind
of information we can determine the
gravitational acceleration and of course
it will change depending on which object
we are considering it would be different
if we plug in the solar mass and the
solar radius or the moon mass and the
moon radius if we consider an astronaut
standing here on on the moon surface now
let's put some numbers into this
equation so we have G is capital G
that's the gravitational constant we
have six point six seven 10 to the 11
and then we have Newton and one over
kilogram squared and mass squared times
the earth mass five point nine seven 10
to the 24 kilograms and then we have to
divide this over through the the earth
radius six point three seven ten to the
sixth and we have to square that and we
have to square the the meters
if we calculate this we get to 9.81
m/s^2
and surely you have seen this number
before this number can either be
calculated if you know capital G the
gravitational constant or you can
determine the gravitational acceleration
through an experiment and together with
the earth mass and earth radius you can
actually calculate the gravitational
constant there